i don't have faith in myself i have
evidence if you have faith in yourself
you're operating on some false almost
delusional level false says like without
evidence i believe evidence says like
here's the information that i have to
make what i think is a good call but i
could be wrong like when i wrote my
first book i didn't have faith that i
could complete it i had evidence that
i've completed hard things before that i
had trained for this that i wasn't a
quitter and so i was willing to make
that leap but the idea that i knew for
certain that i would finish that it
would be a success that i wouldn't
regret walking away from a sure thing to
do an unsure thing i mean that's that's
the whole point
so i've been watching a lot of these
september 11th documentaries obviously
20th anniversary and
watching that it genuinely doesn't feel
real to me it's shaking my worldview a
lot more than i thought it would
watching it back i was
12
something at the time i remember my mum
picking me up from school and it was on
the radio but
that was kind of it but yeah watching
that back it seems
insane that that even happened and then
watching it from the
perspective of the firefighters in the
police offices is ridiculous
yeah it is i was a
freshman in high school so i remember
being on a on a on the west coast time
zone i remember
waking up and it was on the radio and
sort of getting the sense that life
wouldn't be the same again
i think looking you know at it with 20
years distance you i think
uh especially pertaining to the new
books are two two big themes of
immersing me one was the sort of quiet
ordinary heroism that you're talking
about whether it's firefighters or
policemen or just people who are in the
buildings like uh working you know some
people just ran away and some people
said i'm not leaving until i get all of
my people out with me right people who
had no sort of real
legal or professional obligation they
were just
office colleagues sort of
reacting with
extraordinary courage and compassion and
and uh
selflessness and then i think you
contrast that because i've been thinking
a lot about this too obviously it
coincides with the withdrawal from
afghanistan
the
there's sort of two kinds of courage
right there's the courage that uh
charges ahead into a burning building
but there's also
i think courage in
restraint
in sort of seeing a provocation within
its context and so you know the the
terrible tragedy of 9 11 is not just
what happens on that day
but then the immense
uh and mistaken
uh foreign policy that comes after
not just uh you know
i think the the entrance into
afghanistan makes sense what we sort of
do there over the next 20 years makes a
lot less sense what we do what the
united states does in iraq makes almost
no sense in retrospect um and then and
then you look at these successive
presidents and prime ministers who
lacked the courage to be able to say
like what the hell are we doing here
what are we spending all this money and
this manpower and this energy on what
what does this have to do
with the the tragic events that brought
us there in the first place so
in the book i'm talking about courage
it's not just can you run into a
building in the middle of a a terrorist
attack and and save people although
that's really important but also can you
have the courage to
both stick with your convict convictions
and question your convictions can you
um that there was an expression about
lyndon johnson in vietnam war that he
lacked the courage to be seen as a
coward to withdraw from vietnam right
and uh so so courage is an immensely
complicated topic but i think 911 brings
all of its various forms to the
forefront for sure there's a winston
churchill
uh section where
when people encouraging him to try and
go into germany or to throw all of the
forces and he had to show some restraint
as well
yeah so after after france is overrun
the the french uh are like we need the
entirety of the royal air force and we
need it now right like we can't afford
to lose france and and you couldn't and
yet churchill knew that this wasn't the
decisive moment that that the real sort
of opportunity to drive the germans back
wasn't going to be
the british fighting over france it was
going to be the battle of britain and
and and the british sort of fighting uh
in those dark days uh
over over london and and everywhere else
so you know we we
we again we often think of courage as
charging forward but courage is also
restrained courage is also uh you know
holding your fire for the exact right
moment you know quitting your job takes
courage at quitting your job to start a
business
but
the the moment that you choose to do
this is also important right you know
did you prepare enough are you ready is
this actually the opportunity to do it
or is this just the first you know the
first thing that popped into your head
actually i remember i was maybe
22 or 23 but i got my first um
my first book deal
they came to me and they said we want
you to write a book about stoicism and i
remember i went to a mentor of mine and
i said you know this is my dream this is
what i've always wanted to do and i'm
ready to go and he was like you're not
ready um he's like
this book when you do it will be better
if you wait
and
turning that deal down was one of the
hardest things that i've ever done it
wasn't a lot of money or anything but it
was just like that was the thing that i
had wanted accolade and status and
renown and prestige oh i mean even more
than that it was just the shot that i
wanted right like this was like i
thought this was my one and only shot
and to turn it down was terrifying
because you know what if it doesn't come
back but the obstacle is the way it came
out probably
four years after that and it what
my mentor was totally right i was more
prepared i had a better platform i was a
better writer um the the moment in time
was better as well um and so you know if
i if i had rushed if i'd sort of
courageously pursued the opportunity um
i actually would have been worse off
than than
than the discipline uh to sort of check
that impulse
what's the common thread then if we've
got multiple types of courage we have
sort of restraint
and bravery
i i to me i think the the
what all forms of courage have in common
is it's about putting your ass on the
line so it's about it's about risk right
um if it's a for sure if it's a
guarantee if there's no danger you know
we're not talking about courage that
doesn't mean it's not hard that doesn't
mean it's not important but we're not
talking about courage so um there has to
be some element of uncertainty or danger
or risk to it um or or there's no
courage and and does that mean that
something can be risky and dangerous and
uh
not be
be a good idea to do ab absolutely right
um it could also be immensely dangerous
you can be successful but if it's for
the wrong thing you know is that what
we're talking about no um so so this is
a difficult thing to calibrate and going
back all the way to the to the greeks
the idea of like where's the fine line
between courage and recklessness has
always been a long debate so yeah i
don't want to make this seem like it's
an obvious thing or that just like just
because there's risk involved you should
courageously push forward that that's
what the winston churchill story is
about um there was a moment and then the
right moment and the difference between
those two things was everything yeah it
seems like there's a paradigm isn't
there there's a spectrum between
cowardice recklessness and courage is
that right
yeah aristotle calls this the golden
mean and that that courage sits in the
middle between those two vices of
cowardice and recklessness there's a
great story about a spartan um who's
fined uh for fighting without armor like
in the midst of this battle he rips off
and he fights like you know immensely
bravely and and they win um but he's
fined for endangering a spartan asset
right like himself
he took an unnecessary risk yeah and and
i think about that just because it paid
off doesn't mean it was a good idea
right and and it may have been
courageous it might also have been uh
needlessly stupid yeah reckless there's
a difference i think you talk about
between is it bold and rash as well yeah
yeah same thing
yeah just just waiting for the right
moment is is really is really everything
and uh and again this is moral courage
and uh
and physical courage right you know
don't fire between before you see the
whites of their eyes is the expression
from the american revolution but also
you know like let's say um you've seen
something unethical or you believe that
there there's something wrong like at a
company or an industry you're in you
know just getting up and shouting it uh
at the top of your lungs that might be
the morally correct thing to do but what
and there may be a certain amount of
courage to it but i i would argue that
the point of it was to stop it from
happening and so being able to identify
the right moment
or the right plan
or the right uh sort of strategy to
actually make this thing successful to
have the to maximize the impact of what
you're trying to do that also requires
courage so like the person who just sort
of uh says everything that they think
you know uh might might seem courageous
but at a certain point nobody listens to
that person right and it's almost it's
almost not courageous because uh they
never you know have to deal with the
consequences of their actions so to
really sort of stop and think about the
intersection between courage and
self-restraint i think is really
important and it needs to be filtered
through wisdom as well because if you're
deploying it
in service of the wrong thing it's just
you're spray spray gunning it all over
the place
or what if what if you're just
fundamentally incorrect right so uh in
the u.s we have uh all over the world
there's a number of people who are
vaccine resistant let's say but what
about the people who are uh
vaccine
refusers right and
does it take courage to sort of risk
your job or your reputation to reject uh
this thing sure you're also risking
death um but you're fundamentally
incorrect right so so i think
it's not just uh wisdom is like sort of
how you do it but what if what if you're
uh just
misinformed right and so what you're
doing feels courageous and and there is
a certain amount of risk to speaking out
about it sort of uh culturally or you
know financially or whatever um but but
yes the the cause ultimately determines
whether uh it it it it matters there's
some um examples from history that you
talk about to do with famous i think
it's ex-presidents of the uk or advisor
of the us or
who
wrote these great books or had these
fantastic lives but then they were
incredibly courageous around white
supremacy or around discrimination and
it's sort of this very unforgivable
type of courage
well so so kennedy uh famously writes a
book called profiles in courage where he
uh writes about a number of politicians
who did unpopular but what he felt like
were courageous stands and one of the
stands uh he's writing this in the
sixties so about a hundred years after
the u.s civil war uh or sorry he's
writing this in the 50s i guess so a
little less than a hundred years after
the civil war um and one of the one of
the things that we people have often
looked at in in the aftermath of the u.s
of war is the impeachment of andrew
johnson um there's some sort of the the
the north wins the american civil war uh
then lincoln is assassinated his vice
president succeeds him and um uh he
immediately gets sort of bogged down in
these uh political battles over
reconstruction what what what rights are
we going to give african americans how
are we going to rebuild et cetera and so
johnson is uh essentially captured by
southern interests and blocks most of
the reconstruction agenda
an agenda that today we now see was the
right thing but at the time you know uh
tinge with racism was was was not a big
priority but anyways he gets impeached
over some complicated issues that are
not really that important to understand
but he gets impeached uh but a number of
republican uh senators uh block the
impeachment even though uh their party
is the one trying to impeach him um so
so basically uh they
kennedy's view
is that this was a brave political stand
because they were bucking their own
party in defense of the institution of
the presidency um and and and blah blah
blah well
a little more distance we can see a
couple things so one they were really um
they were really sort of blocking this
reconstruction agenda which in
retrospect the fact that the united
states sort of stalled out here is one
of our great moral failings and it's why
uh the civil rights movement has to
happen and it's why we're still
reckoning with civil rights today um
andrew johnson uh should have been
impeached and if he had been impeached
we probably would have been able to uh
heal the wounds of the civil war earlier
and i know i'm getting way off in the
weeds here but the to me the the other
second failure and this is a thing that
happens um
by by blocking the impeachment um it's
now like next to impossible to actually
get rid of an american president like
nixon should have been fully impeached
rather than resigning uh clinton
probably should have been impeached and
removed from office for lying under oath
trump definitely should have been
impeached so
my point is that what kennedy is looking
at he's seeing this as political courage
because they're blocking their political
party they're taking an unpopular stand
but i would actually argue that the real
courageous thing would have been to fire
the guy over doing the wrong thing and
so sometimes what can seem like a
courageous stand
because it was risky you you have to
zoom out and you have to go what am i
really fighting for here right what is
the cause to which i'm aligned if i am
successful what am i bringing into the
world and so like look there was i'm
sure there's all sorts of statues to to
to interesting people in in in britain
uh who were war heroes but if we step
back and go what was this war about
again it it loses some of its luster
right and and i think this is certainly
true of the american civil war lots of
brave people on both sides
but you know when you're fighting for
the enslavement of
a large portion of your population it's
not so admirable so courage has to be in
service of a better world
well yeah so the four virtues right and
we've been bouncing around but basically
i'm doing a series now on these four
virtues the first is courage why is that
exist
um well here i'll say what they all are
and then i'll say why i put them in this
order so
this is the historical order it's not
the one i chose but courage
self-discipline or temperance then
justice and then wisdom
now this dates back uh pre-stoics but is
the sort of core uh ideas that that
stoicism is based around
think courage is first c.s lewis said uh
quite brilliantly that that uh courage
is all the virtues at their testing
point right it's difficult to be
self-disciplined in a world of excess
without courage it's you can't pursue
justice without courage uh justice
without courage is worthless right um
and then to
to to pursue truth of course is i think
the scariest thing of all um so that's
the four disciplines but um
when we're talking about these how these
uh
these
uh
virtues intersect with each other it's
really important that you to realize
that you can't separate them right so
again the pursuit of an idea or a
concept courageously is good but if it's
not in pursuit of justice of making the
world a better place or if conversely
it's in pursuit of injustice right um
that that's that's not a good thing uh
so so you could be a a courageous
business person but if your business is
like raping the environment or you treat
your employees really poorly that's
that's not what this is about
yeah yeah what's the difference between
feeling fear and being afraid because it
feels like fear is the thing that holds
people back from courage
yeah there's a great faulkner quote he
says uh be scared you can't help that
don't be afraid
um i think the distinction is fear is or
being scared is a natural biological
instantaneous reaction we all have
fear um
but it's about what we do after that so
to me being afraid is uh when fear is
made permanent right or when fear is
extended into a state of being right
it's the difference between being angry
and doing something out of anger right
it's okay to be upset by something but
can you keep it under control and can
you make sure that your response is
rational and not emotional um and and
the stoics talk about this like look if
you jump around if you jump out from
behind a corner and scare me i'm going
to have a reaction right that's not no
amount of philosophical training is
going to prevent that from happening
but
a certain amount of training in the case
of a fire fighter or a police officer as
we're talking about can make it so
despite the terror and fear and very
real danger you go into the building
instead of away from the building like
everyone else there's a quote that you
use at the start of the chapter that
says
fear before you're actually in the
battle is a normal emotional reaction
it's the last step of preparation the
not knowing this is where you'll prove
you're a good soldier that first fight
the fight with yourself will have gone
then you will be ready to fight the
enemy and that was a british soldier
handbook or something
well i found i actually found uh i found
it i bought a really old rare copy of it
because i heard the quote somewhere but
basically it there was a handbook that
every soldier at least in the u.s forces
i don't know if it went out to all the
allied forces but i i suppose it might
have um but in and mine is dated like
1943 and like you can see the name of
the soldier in it um like it's his
personal copy um but but the idea was
that um they basically took all these
people who had no training no experience
they were not lifelong you know sort of
military uh figures and they they they
trained them to go fight in battle and
part of that training was this book and
they were talking about exactly what
we're talking about which is the first
battle
is not with the enemy but it's with that
internal enemy your own doubts your own
fear your own questions um and you have
to overcome that to be able to proceed
and i don't think anyone is again no one
is saying that brave people don't feel
those things in fact they do they might
even feel them more than you uh but what
makes them impressive what they what
they manage to accomplish is what they
do in spite of those doubts and fears
and worries and dangers
i like the fact that in that quote it
reminds us that you have challenges that
you can control yourself and that by
overcoming those that is the first step
on the way to controlling the challenges
that are outside of you
i would say that and i would also say
that it's also the first step
collectively right so we go like how do
how do you make an army brave right or
how do you make a company brave well
there's nothing you can do for everyone
else but you can deal with your doubts
and fears and that is contagious there's
a great expression that courage is
contagious so is calmness
so by by dealing with what you control
which is like here's what i'm feeling
here's how i'm going to work through
what i'm feeling here's what i'm going
to do despite those feelings that
affects not only your own actions but it
ripples through the people around you
you know panic is also contagious
doubt is contagious uh you know as we've
seen during the pandemic not only is the
is the virus
profoundly contagious but so is you know
sort of selfish thinking so are
conspiracy theories right so is anger so
these emotions are also very contagious
and and when we keep them in check or we
we triumph over them we are also having
a positive impact on the people around
us how can people overcome fear then
because it's a very visceral emotion
like it's sure so
overpowering
of course of course and look there's
obviously different kinds of fear and
different levels of fear but i think we
start by like
thinking about it right so much of what
we fear is just this kind of vague
notion this sort of like well what's the
worst case scenario how bad is it going
to be um
what if i do this what we sort of just
our mind races instead of taking a
minute and really thinking about it the
stoics talk about putting every
impression to the test sort of uh they
they talk about it it's like you know
when you pass like uh
you you spend like a large bill at a at
an establishment they they put the thing
up to the light or they run the marker
over it to see if it's counterfeit and i
think that's something that's a good
analogy when you're thinking about
courage is like is what i'm thinking
here based on anything real or uh
is it is it this in my own head um
there's a great acronym for fear uh
false emotions appearing real
and so often what what our fears are
have almost no basis in fact or reality
um but it's this thing we've made up in
our head that feels real
i couldn't believe that the most
repeated phrase in the bible was to do
with fear
yeah be not afraid um
do you know how many times it's in there
uh many times there's one one reading of
it is that it's in there like more than
365 times which from what i found is not
the case but but it's many many many
times i mean i know it appears like a
dozen times in the odyssey as well it's
sort of this if you think of it and as
soon as you think about it you realize
that that's a very common almost trope
in literature right it's like the person
is afraid and then the angel
or a god or a mentor or an obi-wan helps
them transcend it yeah yeah yeah it says
says uh you know don't be afraid
remember your training or like don't be
afraid remember what i told you or like
it's gonna be okay like i'm looking out
for you right so so that that is like
the constant battle of the human species
which is that we're really afraid of
something
but there's a part of us or a memory or
a an instructor or a guide or whatever
that we have
that
reminds us
that we've got this and that we should
proceed
does that mean
that
we have collectively
we have a duty to help other people be
courageous
i think so yeah i think so i mean look i
think the first the first battle is with
your own fear right like most of us are
called to do something and then we don't
do it um or or we see something then we
go i don't want to get involved or we
feel compelled to act or contribute to
something and then we go ah
but like what if it goes badly or what
if i get criticized or whatever right so
i think our first duty is to our own
destiny like am i gonna courageously do
what i'm put on this planet but i do so
basically in the book i sort of split it
up i think first is the battle with fear
then is this triumph over fear which is
courage but the highest level of courage
is when you call courage out of the
people around you when you inspire other
people to be better when you make other
people better so i do think we have a
duty to um
make uh to to help other people who are
faltering in moments of cowardice or
fear or whatever um but i really feel
like uh
you first have to get your own house in
order yeah so after we've stress tested
the fear what comes next because there's
still times where you don't know you're
able to kid yourself into believing that
this thing is real where did they go
next
yeah i mean i think that after you sort
of battled with this fear then you you
go right like you you take that first
step and i think you know it's been
interesting the couple moments uh where
i've sort of taken big swings in my life
whether it was dropping out of college
and leaving my corporate job to become a
writer um you're very you're terrified
right you're like this is going to go so
poorly uh what about this what about
this what about this you know maybe
people you know or care about in my case
with my parents i might want to drop me
to college don't do it you know like
people trying to actively hold you back
um
and uh but what i well the interesting
thing is like once once it's in motion
shakespeare talks about how um the
between like the consideration in the
act is this sort of torture
but it's like once you go
it's it all falls away right and so i
think that's really kind of the next
part it's like just actually actually
doing it because once you've done it
you're too busy to be afraid right
you're like dropping out of college the
decision to go into the office and fill
out the paperwork that was terrifying
but immediately after
like now i have to figure out what the
hell i'm doing with my life right now i
don't have time to think about whether
it was the right decision or not because
it's done so i think that the the going
is is really the next battle
those liminal spaces in between are the
ones that hurt i had a neuroscientist on
news talking about our brain's desire
for closure and this is one of the
reasons why when you have missing
persons you know the the 911 perfect
example all of the names and faces
stapled it was a thousand people
thousands of people that weren't ever
found bodies not found no one identified
and it's just that people
they needed to know even if the news was
terrible
i think that's right i mean i think one
of the scariest things in the world is
that uncertainty and this is why we
don't make decisions right and i have a
chapter on this in the book but but like
the path
the confidence and courage it takes to
make to say like i don't have all the
information
i don't know if this is the right call
or not but i have enough information
that i'm going to do it right like there
you know there's that um
there's that expression and i do like it
it has some value but that expression of
like it's either hell yes or hell no
right um that's great except for i was
like 51 49 on most of the most important
decisions on my life in my life but to
go when you're 100 is easy to go when
you're
not sure at all that's what that's what
courage is about right like again we
talked i said this earlier like if you
know for certain it's not a big deal um
but but to make to to decide like hey
i've seen enough i'm gonna do this or um
like
yeah this might this might blow up on
our faces but we don't have any other
choice or you know hey as you said with
911 like
obviously it's not
a hundred percent confirmed but like i
have to move i have to grieve like i
have to move on with my life i have to
accept this incredibly painful
heartbreaking thing that that takes
courage right it's easier to sit with
the uncertainty or the false hope right
um to look reality in the face and go i
don't have a choice i have to do this
difficult thing
like
fear courage that's that battle for sure
i like the idea of stress testing the
fears to see if they're real and then
committing to action based on what you
know i think that yeah taking that first
step as soon as you get through the
little liminal doorway i think that
seems to be a
a good
prescription i i wrote a piece a couple
years ago and and sort of my philosophy
which is like i don't have faith in
myself i have evidence right if you have
faith in yourself you're operating on
some false almost delusional level right
false says like without evidence i
believe right um
uh evidence says like here's the
information that i have to make what i
think is a good call but i could be
wrong right like when i wrote my first
book i didn't have faith that i could
complete it i had evidence that i've
completed hard things before
that i had trained for this
that i wasn't a quitter and so i was
willing to make that leap but the idea
that i knew for certain that i would
finish that it would be a success that
it that i wouldn't regret you know
walking away from a sure thing to do an
unsure thing i mean that's that's the
whole point you don't know that could
cause people to sell themselves short
sometimes
how so that a lot of the time we are
unaware of our own capacities
that if you are the sort of person who
is inclined to downplay your ability
that you may constantly be living with
too much being left on the table
we you do have to be able to step back
and see yourself from a distance
sometimes that means hey i'm not as
great as i think i am other times it's
oh like i may be underselling myself as
you said like one of the reasons that i
was confident in the decision i made is
that although i didn't quite see it
people that i trusted and admired who
advised me they did see it so i had i
was willing to trust their view perhaps
a little bit more than my own when when
my mentor said don't write this book you
know it's too early again same thing i
wanted to do it i thought i could do it
um but i but i wanted to trust this
external assessment more um and and and
that that was also a bit of a leap as
well so yeah i i think it's a tension so
like if you don't believe you can do
something it's very unlikely that you'll
be able to do it but just because you
believe you can do something doesn't
mean you can so that's the tension right
like if you don't believe you can do it
or if you believe something's impossible
it's impossible for you right like
you're not going to be the one that does
it um
so that that that's that is the the that
is the difficult tension it's the
million dollar question like um
you know
what whether you've got whether you're
what am i capable of yeah
yeah what were they and how do you do it
on something you've never done before
how do you know on something you've
never done before
this is what i spoke to seth godin about
talking about imposter syndrome and he
said well
if you're doing something that you
haven't done before by its very nature
you should have imposter syndrome you're
treading untrodden ground this is
trailblazing this part of the map hasn't
been terrained out yet like imposter
syndrome comes along for the ride as you
break new new boundaries
um i suppose what you're saying here is
that with the evidence behind you you
should be able to extrapolate forward
okay
what can i
realistically expect to be able to
achieve here
yeah i mean my ego is the enemy book i
think uh
i talk about this tension a little bit
so
um if if you
don't have any doubts there's probably
some ego at play right um but also if
you're consumed by imposter syndrome
like all you're thinking about is like
they're out to get me they they think i
don't have what it takes they're
whispering about me behind my back
you're probably also exaggerating your
importance to other people like nobody
gives a [ __ ] they're not thinking about
you at all right so so often the
imposter syndrome or the cowardice is
like overestimating your importance
right so like people will go like well
this is really bad uh but i don't want
to get involved yet because later in the
future i'll be in a position where i
have even more influence and then i'll
get involved uh or or they tell
themselves and this was very common with
trump a lot of the enablers obviously
there was the real toxic sort of true
believers but there was also the trump
followers who were who considered
themselves the adults in the room right
and this is actually
very similar to seneca's relationship
with nero um like
i'm very important i'm a check against
the bad impulses of this person so i
might not agree with what they're doing
and i might think that it's wrong but
i'm going to stay here because i'm
preventing it from being as bad as it
could be the ego in that is again that
you're overestimating your importance
you're not that important at all nobody
cares so so ego can sort of trip us up
either by making us uh
you know sort of unaware of our
capacities or uh
disingenuously overstate our capacities
to ourselves what were these spartan
temples of fear
um i i think the idea is that like you
would pay um
you would pay your respects to fear
like you would pray to the idea of god
as a fear to
uh
to to know right like that and i think
this is also the point if you pretend
that it doesn't exist that you don't
feel it you're probably
making things more dangerous than sort
of respecting it right it's like um i
think again we've seen this during the
virus like people are going like i don't
want to live my life in fear you're
afraid of it it's like i'm not afraid of
it i'm just taking it seriously right
because it it's real and its
consequences are real and you have to be
an idiot not to
uh to to see what it is right so i i
don't think acknowledging that something
is scary or dangerous or or that the
odds are stacked against you or that you
might not make it out alive or whatever
it is you're facing the situation i
don't think that's fearful i think
that's actually part of
the process of then stepping forward
courageously to do what needs to be done
what about marcus aurelius is there a
particularly courageous moment that you
like from your research on him
yeah i mean i think just just the the
the decision to accept the
incredible sort of destiny
burden that that's forced it upon him um
he's going to be more a character in my
book and self-discipline but
you know marcus to realize he's not born
uh to be the king he's born to just like
an ordinary
uh upper-class roman family and the
emperor hadrian sees something in him
as like a very young man and sort of
sets up this process where he eventually
becomes emperor but like if you had
asked marcus to realize what do you want
to do with your life he probably would
have said anything but be in charge in
fact he weeps uh when when told that you
know the throne is his he he cries
um again the idea that the stokes don't
have any emotions doesn't hold up but um
he he because he's aware of what a
terrible job most kings have done and he
doesn't want to do that um and so i
think for mark surely the decision to
accept the immensity of the
responsibility you know you look at like
pictures of obama when he takes office
versus when he leaves office and you're
like oh man fully job
yeah that this this job uh takes its
toll and so i think you know just a
pretty ordinary example for marcus to
realize is like
does he does the hard thing instead of
running away from it looking back do you
think he was do you think he took
pleasure or satisfaction from doing what
he did
i mean i think he he came to take
a lot of pride in being good at it and
not not going the way of his
predecessors
but i think he saw it more of a duty
than as a pleasure yeah yeah um there's
some people who you know are
desire power um and you know
occasionally they make good leaders but
i would say more often than not the best
leaders are the ones who want nothing to
do with the power or responsibility
i was thinking about what would happen
if everybody in the world was courageous
do you think it would be
too
chaotic if if everybody was trying to be
in the vanguards do you know what i mean
yeah it's an interesting hypothetical um
you know does does uh
there's an expression i think it was at
iwo jima in in talking about you know
the men raised the that famous flag and
someone said uh where uncommon valor was
common virtue basically like everyone
was courageous right which is
extraordinarily rare
you know if if everyone acted with
uncommon valor would valor then become
less valuable the overton window of
valor's moved again yeah
yeah i pro probably um but look you know
we've been recording some version of
like our historical epics for 5 000
years um i think the reason that these
stories still resonate with us is that
it never has been and likely never will
be
uh common it you know you you'll you'll
hear like a hero will save someone from
in front of a train or something and
they go i just did what anyone would
have done and it's like no you didn't
like it wouldn't be a big story if
anyone would have done that yeah right
and and they were
you're it's not that you're lying but
you're being uh talk about what you're
talking about earlier you're being um
uh you're selling yourself short because
there were other people there when this
happened and you were the only one right
so uh i i think it would be a very
wonderful champagne problem to have if
courage was too ubiquitous yeah yeah
yeah um but but i i suspect that that's
never gonna be uh never gonna be the
status quo what about social pressure
because that is a big limitation on
people being courageous
well uh i think
thankfully you know there's social
pressure to be courageous right like we
we hold it up as
i think one of the paradoxes of courage
is that we all admire it and then it's
rare right so like there and and there
have been certain societies versus
others that have really prioritized
courage the spartans of course being one
but i i i get your point which is that
um often the reason we are not
courageous is that we're worried what
other people will think that's probably
the most common fear um and the
character i used to tell the story is
florence nightingale in the book you
know she's born to this immense british
family of means um doesn't have to do
anything she gets called to nursing
and her parents are like we'd rather you
be a prostitute like like they're like
this is the worst thing you could
possibly do what will our friends think
and so her battle was not against
disease or danger on the battlefield it
was
against the expectations of what a woman
should be doing it was against the
desire of her codependent family it was
you know against comfort and against uh
you know the status quo and being alone
and carving out a new path in life so
didn't she spend like 17 years in that
liminal space that we were talking about
yes a very very very long time and you
could see it as two ways right um either
she's ignoring the call right as part of
the hero's journey there's the refusal
of the call and i think that's part of
it
but she's also gathering up the
determination and the strength and the
belief and the skills necessary to do it
so i mean
to me
that that it took 16 years
is secondary to the fact that she did it
right if it if it took her whole life
and she never did it that would be a
real problem that it took 16 years i'd
rather it take 16 years and then you get
a florence nightingale out of the other
side then again she courageously plunges
into the fray at 20 years old or
whatever but is incapable
and
unqualified for
the challenge that she embraced
isn't it sad that lots of the people
who had been the most courageous were
alienated when they were alive and it's
sort of only after they're dead that
their actions get recognized so i'm
thinking about like maybe like a galileo
but that's that's why courage is so
important right it's like you're doing
it because it's the right thing
right not because you think there'll be
a payoff right obviously you hope and it
would be wonderful if courage was always
recognized if genius was always welcomed
you know if good deeds never went
unpunished
but that's just not how it goes i think
uh churchill said that you know every
prophet has to go through the wilderness
right that means the time that you spend
away um
whether it's 40 nights or in his case
almost 10 years but he said it's from
this that psychic dynamite is made what
was i actually what was the time in the
wilderness for churchill so churchill
after the first world war the failures
at gallipoli and his sort of somewhat
out of step political views basically he
loses uh his his cabinet posts and then
his sort of persona non grata in his
political party and he spends like 10
years at chartwell um what's up
basically a non-figure in british
political life
cool and then he gets brought back in
because they need
some reinforcements yeah and and the
irony is had he been involved in british
political life the way that he wanted to
he would have been soiled like he would
have been if not complicit when when the
british people finally woke up and said
oh man we totally messed up here like
we're at war and we're unprepared they
threw the whole government out right so
he would have been tossed out with the
bathwater so the irony is that by being
sent away he actually had the distance
uh to cultivate uh not just the the
viewpoint that he needed and the the
political base that he needed um but you
could also argue i mean he was an old
man he was like 60 years old when this
happened so he could have also just
retired and so in a way he gets like a
10-year break like he he rests
and i'm not sure he would have been able
to have the third act of his political
life without that you know sort of bit
of stillness have you heard of dietrich
bonhoeffer
yeah
for sure sick guy what story man like
yes yeah such a such an interesting
story
very very much so uh and he's he's a
character in the book i mean you know
to me what i loved about bonhoeffer is
is he he's comes from a wealthy german
family he's opposed to nazism he's a
he's a christian pastor but his family
gets him out
of germany in like
1933 or 34 he he makes it to new york
now he's not jewish so he's not like
worried about being
sent to a concentration camp but he was
uh
an outspoken opponent of hitler and nazi
politics so he was a marked man
so he gets sent away he's free right he
could have spent the war as many great
figures did you know trying to make a
difference from exile
but he realizes almost immediately
that um to to sit out the war in safety
in the united states would be um if not
cowardice it would be
uh
contrary to what he felt his christian
duty was so he gets back on a boat and
he goes back to germany where he he he
sort of actively conspires to
assassinate hitler
and is killed for it but again i think
the assassination attempt and the death
are brave no question but it takes on a
whole
kind of transcendent level to realize
like he didn't have to do any of it and
he was dead by
39 or so i don't think he made it to his
40th birthday yeah very very young very
young
yeah it's terrifying man
thinking about people's fear of
growth and change
that i think that there's another layer
of
guilt or shame to it because
sometimes we know that there isn't a big
line at the door it's just this sort of
very internal battle between us and the
the new job or the the leaving the
relationship or the telling your
co-worker that what they're doing is is
making you feel bad like that it's these
little things right
well in those cases you're you're still
leaving safety behind right the safety
of silence the safety of the status quo
um the safety of a safety net right and
the decision to
uh to change to work on yourself one of
the the sort of examples i talk about is
like tiger woods deciding to reinvent
his golf swing
right imagine you're one of the best in
the world and you go ah but to get to
the next level
i have to break down this thing that's
working
and
rebuild it from the ground up which
means i'm gonna be bad for a period
that's it where you think about reid
hastings and netflix he has a
multi-billion dollar business shipping
people dvds right and he says
that's not the future i'm gonna jettison
all of that and become a streaming
platform um
people don't do that right i mean the
reason we talk about businesses being
disrupted
is because they don't disrupt themselves
what was the story about you at american
apparel
oh at the end of the book yeah
yeah i i tell a story at the end of the
book about sort of being asked to do
something unethical at work and you know
i wanted to conclude the book not with a
story of like heroism but like a sort of
a more sobering reminder of like how
complicated the world is and and how
often we've we can fall short myself uh
being no exception of that and and so i
got asked to do this thing and
um i really struggled with it and i
decided that it was the wrong thing to
do and i wasn't going to do it but
that's like as far as i took it right i
didn't stop it from happening
um
and i think the reason i didn't stop it
from happening is that i didn't want to
lose my job i was willing to risk my job
to a certain degree by saying like
that's not for me find someone else
but i wasn't willing to
essentially quit the job uh or or get
fired by actively opposing the thing
and the the irony is the thing i
struggle with looking back at it is like
why did i want to keep a job
that
by doing the right thing i would have
lost right so that's that's kind of the
strange thing about these moments of
cowardice right we're protecting some we
we tell ourselves we're protecting
something or someone
in fact we're almost always degrading or
risking or damaging the very thing right
so again we tell ourselves oh oh if i
leave then there won't be any other
adults in the room or we tell ourselves
like but you know i did i worked so hard
i shouldn't have to you know but it's
like that doesn't age well and that's
part of the reason i wanted to tell the
story is that it was morally complex at
the time right i was like well what
about this and what about this and what
about this and there wasn't even any
public scrutiny this was all private but
in retrospect it doesn't age well at all
you know it's like
the right thing is obvious
and so it's not that it's in hindsight
it's obvious it's that um all my reasons
at the time were just sort of short-term
[ __ ] that uh i should have had the
courage to be able to see past it's the
difference between
being complicit because of omission and
being complicit because of commission
yes yeah marcus really says look you can
commit injustice by doing nothing also
right and like so i didn't do the thing
and
i don't act that way and it's not
something i approved and i expressed my
disapproval
but it happened anyway but you know
the tolerance right you knew that not
complying probably wouldn't get you
fired but also would give you the get
out of jail free card that would make
future ryan perhaps feel less uh
culpable
i covered my uh i risked my ass but i
also covered my ass right into the to
the perfect balance right um and and
look it is it is complicated though
because let's say i had just quit on
principle it probably still would have
happened right so i would feel better
about myself in that sense um but uh you
know flash forward three or so years
later i was in a position to hold this
person accountable uh and uh you know
ended up um you know sort of bringing
justice about in that sense um so it's
it it's complicated right it's never a
clear cut um and
i guess the question is and this is the
always the revisionist what if is like
perhaps if i had stood up or been more
vocal if this had spurred me earlier
that thing might not have happened three
years in the future but maybe it would
have happened one year in the future or
maybe it would have been brought about
in that very moment so you know it's
complicated how do people not lambast
themselves for not being as courageous
as they should have been at the time
yeah it's uh it's complicated again um i
guess the stoics would say like
whipping yourself accomplishes nothing
learning from it makes you better so for
me i try to think about and i have tried
to think about um
you know not like oh am i a piece of
[ __ ] you know am i hypocrite do i should
i you know uh you know do i need to uh
how do i punish myself for this um and i
try to think more about how can i learn
about this go learn from this going
forward how can i identify whatever sort
of insidious logic you know was it was
was going on in my head at the time and
then also
by writing about it you know how do i
how do i sort of help people uh learn
from the example as well so you know
lambasting yourself probably uh
uh doesn't move the ball forward much
also i guess focusing on action as you
said sort of stress testing the ideas
and then looking at what's the next step
that's going to help to
um
pattern interrupt the neuroticism it's
going to stop you from doing things
you're too busy actually making a thing
happen hopefully with a little bit more
wisdom
one sometimes you hear from people who
have really dropped the ball or really
failed they're like i'm a coward so they
they actually they label themselves how
to identify with their own failures yeah
exactly becomes sort of part of the
identity and thus makes it even less
likely that in the future uh you'll be
able to to step up you you want to
ideally like when i when i look at that
i don't see that as like
um uh like proof of who i am to me it's
me falling short of who i am
right so i identify with like the higher
self and the lower self was what i did
and the journey and the the hard work is
in getting those closer together is
william tynedale in the book
i don't think so who's that the guy that
translated the bible into english for
the first time
so he was he's a pretty cool story so he
got arrested and executed but it was
originally that the bible was only ever
in latin because it wasn't supposed to
be that the common people in the common
parlance were able to read it and it was
sort of this gatekeeping thing going on
with the church you can only access god
through us this sort of bourgeois
um yeah the restriction of access from
the normal people
wow no no that that's fascinating cool
guy really really cool guy thinking
about what you just said there
is a responsibility for people who have
more power to be more courageous because
you've got more to lose but your impact
could be greater but
you've worked so hard for 40 years in
this company to try and get yourself
there and you're probably more
conservative in your values and
it's difficult
that's really the problem with this idea
of like oh when i have more power or
influence then i will do it because you
won't because actually you have you'll
have a million reasons more in the
future not to do it and this is kind of
the tension you know we're often
surprised when leaders are not
courageous and it's like well how long
has this person been in public service
30 years
well
how do you think they survived a 30-year
career in public service it was by
covering their ass instead of risking
their ass
so so the irony is that oftentimes as
you work your way up through the the
ranks you're not becoming more
courageous you're actually becoming less
courageous because it's
filtering out the people who
resist who stand up who say unpleasant
truths um so i do think there is a
higher responsibility the more influence
or power you have i think about this
with my own platform are there things
that i know that by talking about it
will cost me fans or money i wanted to
dig into that because the last year
you've been more outspoken i think about
some pretty contentious topics whether
that be vaccine hesitancy whether that
be mass mandates whether that be trump
and stuff like that and i think you've
mentioned
it's
you've damaged or at least uh metric
wise objectively this has hurt this has
hurt your following can you just dig
into that for me
yeah uh
to me
so sometimes i'll i'll write something
maybe and i i don't actually think that
i'm particularly political i feel like
i'm often talking about like sort of
basic social contract issues i'm not
like oh you know we need to pass this
bill or you know i really don't get
involved in specific political issues
but i'm just talking about sort of in
the we're talking about justice i talk
about sort of basic issues of justice or
fairness or caring about people um but
someone will write something why did you
have to say this
you must have known it would piss people
like me off or something and i usually
reply something it depends on what kind
of mood i'm in but um like i didn't
build a large platform i didn't become a
writer um to have this microphone to
then not say what i think out of fear of
offending people in fact i got here by
saying what i think and i'm going to
continue to say what i think because not
only is it my moral obligation as a
citizen but it's also my professional
obligation as
uh a person who identifies like as a
writer like to me the job of a writer is
to say unpleasant or unpopular truths or
just to say the truth generally not to
tell people what they want to hear
um
i i tend to find that most of the people
who are offended by that stuff are not
uh actually your fans and don't actually
matter like you know it's interesting
like i'll let's say i'll criticize like
a republican president um
i'll get a bunch of angry emails from
random people and then i'll get like
emails from actual republicans in office
who'll be like oh i like today's email
that was well set like so so i tend to
find that smart
intelligent people can understand uh and
disagree it's usually very fragile
people who themselves are sort of afraid
of being challenged that get the most
upset when someone disagrees but like
one of the the sort of
one of the things that i try to live by
as a person who
writes about ideas that are primarily
not mine right like i write about stoke
philosophy i am not the founder or
of stoic philosophy right so if writes
about this thing
um who people identify with that those
ideas then i feel that i have a duty or
an obligation to be a good steward of
the tradition and the values of the
tradition so
could i would it be more profitable and
more pleasant to only talk about
uh the resiliency side of stoicism and
the productivity side of stoicism and
the courageous fun parts of stoicism yes
um but but to me that would be
neglecting the other i mean justice is
one of the four virtues so the idea that
i'm not going to talk about it because
some people might uh be triggered by
what the stoic's definition of justice
is you know um that's it that's just
that's just how it shakes out
one of the interesting things that i've
learned over the last couple of months
is how people like yourself and sam
harris and eric weinstein are two other
examples of people that do this
they
purposefully prune their audience
uh they actively go out of their way
they realize that kind of like barnacles
on the hull of a ship that they've
picked up some flotsam and jetson and
they kind of need to get rid of it and
they actually go out of their way to
self-destruct a little bit the sort of
performer um amputation on a part of
themselves and i think i actually think
that playing chess with cancel culture
in this way
is
i think you're going to see more of it
well maybe you're not going to see more
of it because by its very nature it's
quite complex and sort of multifaceted
it's brazilian jiu jitsu lexically um
but
i i got fascinated by i really really
did get fascinated because the the show
has grown a lot like ten fold since the
last time that you were on
and i great thank you um
and i'm like [ __ ] hell like how do i
avoid audience capture who's actually
here for the things that are supposed to
be here and um
yeah learning
that as a tool man like actively going
out of your way to say things that you
know would trigger
the people that you don't want to be
there
is a really smart tactic i don't know if
i'm actively trying to trigger or turn
people off but i can lean into it a
little bit uh some sometimes i guess but
i i think what i've sort of realized is
this like and i i really noticed this
when i started talking about certain
things that were getting kind of an
unexpected backlash
and
what it what i realized sort of doing
the math honestly was that
as the books have really uh and the
different kinds of content that i do has
really taken off um a bunch of like i
thought this was all kind of this small
audience and we've grown together we're
all on the same page and then you
realize actually no
people heard about you from the
algorithm they heard about you from this
article you know they got refer
they may have come to you and thought
that you were about one thing when
actually you're about the other thing
and so you have to be very
audience capture is when
you
try to be what the audience wants to be
as opposed to being who you actually are
does that make sense yep so what i just
try to do is like who am i what do i
think what's important to me that's what
i'm gonna say and then as the stoics
talk about i'm indifferent to whether
that gets me more fans or less fans
right so i don't care either way because
what's important to me is that i say
what i think is important to the people
that i'm trying to communicate with
right so i'm not necessarily trying to
drive people away but i'm definitely not
not saying things
because i'm worried that people will
leave
and if you are worried that people are
leaving not only are you
failing them by not telling them what
they need to hear you're also depriving
your actual audience of truths that they
are equipped to deal with and need to
hear and so it's kind of a double
failure yeah you end up trying to be
your version of someone else which means
that at the very very best you're going
to be the second best in the world at
whatever you choose to do because you're
never going to do what somebody else
does better than them
yes and look you're it's also a risk
like people think oh it's safer not to
do it but it's also risky to to not be
yourself because eventually you'll get
hammered for being complicit for being
silent um you know for ignoring what's
happening in the world i think about
this with my kids like part of why i
talk about what i talk about i take the
stands i want to take it's like my kids
are going to ask me in 10 or 20 years to
be like hey when this thing was
happening what did you do and i don't
want to say oh i wrote a lot of
self-improvement articles do you know
what i mean like i like i don't want to
say oh i was really i was i was really
concerned about growing my email list so
i sort of sat that one out
awesome lead magnets yeah yeah that's
not going to age well yeah
james stockdale that story about him
beating himself up and trying to kill
himself can you tell us
well he's one of the the great american
heroes of the of the later 20th century
and
um one of the the sort of last most
famous sort of explicit students of the
stokes he reads epictetus when he's a
graduate student at stanford which the
navy had sent him to and shortly
thereafter he gets shot down over
vietnam
and there's sort of two seminal moments
in his time he spends like seven years
in this prisoner of war camp like one of
the worst
uh prisoner of war camps in history a
horrible human rights uh injustice but
um
like he's there for like two days and
they wanted to go on camera and say
you know everyone's nice here this is
great
and uh and so they say go into the
bathroom and shave
and come back and we'll film this thing
and while he's in the bathroom he cuts a
gash across his forehead
and so he can't so he can't be filmed
and they they patch it up and uh they
try to make him go on camera anyway so
he grabs a stool and he beats his face
to a giant puffy mess so it's like
literally impossible for him to to film
this video and then later in the camp um
later in the camp he when the torture
gets really really bad
um he attempts to kill himself because
he's now sort of well known for being in
the camp and he attempts to kill himself
sort of in an act of defiance and
protest of the torture um so it's not
that he's killing himself to escape the
torture he's making a statement or a a
sort of a public challenge to the the
captors that would have publicly
embarrassed them to a degree that uh you
know might might have massively
escalated the war effort so in these
sort of two moments he puts his physical
appearance safety well-being and then
even his life
uh on the line to protect
both his duty to his country uh and then
also to the his fellow prisoners that's
the transcending that's the heroic
element of courage right
yeah look the courage to start your own
business is real right uh i talk about
michael jordan michael jordan leaving
basketball to play
minor league baseball courageous scary
terrifying
really interesting um maya moore walking
away from the wnba
to
get a man wrongly convicted out of
prison you know is a different level of
courage uh and selflessness right she's
not she's risking it but she doesn't get
the benefit of it she's not risking it
because she wants to go play baseball
she's risking it because she can't live
with herself uh if this guy uh you know
spends one more day unnecessarily in
jail
hmm
what's the best james stockdale book
because every time that i read something
of yours he gets brought up but i don't
know what to read
he wrote a number of
like little short books there's
unfortunately not a great biography of
him but he has a short book called
courage under fire
that's sort of about uh stoicism and his
time in that prison camp
and then jim collins talks about him a
lot in good to great as well
um someone should do that sherman should
put all of that together somebody that's
someone that's listening have you read
alistair erica's the forgotten
highlander
oh dude
i'll write this down bro this is
this is
the most ryan holiday book that i can
think of um so this guy who is in the
sky the forgotten highlander by aleister
rokhart
scottish regiment uh working in i want
to say singapore uh when vietnam go to
war with america
gets captured by
when japan got war with america gets
captured by the japanese builds the
bridge over the river kwai
gets put in a forced labor camp
for
basically four years constantly has
dysentery in every tropical disease
under the sun gets locked on one of
these hell ships which is a tin box with
no food or water out at sea in 40 degree
heat for a month then he gets knocked
off his feet
by the nagasaki bomb blast as he's
working 30 miles from it
stays silent for 50 years because the
army told him to and then finally writes
this memoir as a call to account for the
japanese for the atrocities that they've
gone through it's one of my top 10
all-time favorite books it's outstanding
well i wrote this down and i'm going to
look up william tyndale as well
sick but look ryan man
courage
is
very much needed it seems like at the
moment in the 21st century
and we are in short supply courageous
calling will be linked in the show notes
below where should people go to keep up
to date with you the stuff that you do
um i do an email uh totally for free
about stoicism every single day uh
dailystock.com
and at daley stoke and ryan holiday on
pretty much every platform i love it man
until next time thanks
congrats on the growth thank you man
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed
peace